a white house deputy press secretary has
been suspended
not fired for threatening a female
reporter even
after president biden promised a
zero-tolerance policy
for such language on inauguration day
that's according to the
reporter from politico fox news media
analyst and host of fox's media buzz
howard kurtz
is following this story the white house
decision today to suspend deputy press
secretary tj ducklow
is rooted in his romantic relationship
with axios reporter and nbc contributor
alexi mccammond
they became friends when she covered joe
biden's campaign and he was biden's
national press secretary
well let's get a few things straight the
vice president was not against the
travel ban first of all axios is backing
mccabin saying when the two started
dating in november
though that wasn't publicly disclosed
editors switched her from the biden beat
to covering progressives but also vice
president kamala harris
and she still wrote and talked about
biden when politico called the white
house about the potential conflict of
interest
ducklow and mccammon spoke instead to
people magazine
for a soft focused feature on their
courtship emphasizing that ducklow is
battling cancer
we're both really happy we wanted to do
it the right way duckload told the
magazine
but ducklow also called a political
reporter and shoot her out
for asking about his private life what
ducklow did to the political reporter
was
was more personal and vicious than we
typically see in the
in the very tough exchanges that may
happen between reporter and source this
story was essentially
memory hold by the entire media i don't
think that would have happened
under the trump administration that
conduct clearly violated an early
warning
from president biden if you're ever
working with me and i hear you treat
another colleague with disrespect
talk down to someone i promise you i
will fire you on the spot
press secretary jenn saki said of
today's one week suspension
he's the first to acknowledge this is
not the standard of behavior set out by
the president
nor is it the standard of behavior set
by me in addition to his initial apology
he sent the reporter a personal note
expressing his profound regret it's hard
to understand why axios would bar
alexi mccammon from covering biden
because of her boyfriend
but not biden's vice president and white
house officials may have had little
choice in light of the president's
pledge
but to make an example of tj ducklow
brett
howie thanks new details meantime are